good evening my name is Paul resume a
junior here at hillsdale college
studying speech and theatre and tonight
I'm honored to introduce you to dr. phil
gramm now before I start dr. Arnn has
required that I tell a joke
unfortunately I don't know any good
jokes so I'm going to steal one from
President Reagan Reagan said balancing
the budget is a little like protecting
your virtue you just have to learn to
say no phil gramm serves as vice
chairman of UBS Investment Bank dr.
Graham holds a PhD from the University
of Georgia and economics previously
served 24 years in Congress including
the last 18 years as a senator from
Texas prior to that he taught economics
prior to that he taught economics at
Texas A&M University his legislative
record includes bills such as the Graham
lot of budgets which reduced federal
spending rebuilt National Defense and
mandated the reagan tax cut and the
Graham Redman Act which placed the first
binding constraints on federal spending
as chairman of the Banking Committee
senator Graham was responsible for
legislation modernizing the banking
insurance and securities laws the
gramm-leach-bliley act repealed the 70
year old glass-steagall act which
prohibited banks securities firms and
insurance companies from affiliating he
has published numerous articles and
books on subjects ranging from monetary
theory and policy to private property to
the economics of mineral extraction and
now to speak to us about Reagan and
economics please welcome senator phil
gramm
thank you very much as Paul mentioned
I'm sort of in my third life I was a
college professor and an economist in my
first life and then I was in public
service for 24 years and I guess it's
fair to say anything having anything to
do with money in American government for
24 years I was involved in my mother
once heard me say say that and said well
if it's true I wouldn't brag about it
and then I turned 60 and I started
thinking what are you going to do when
you grow up and so I decided that oughta
make a rational decision about whether
Iran again so i got all my grandfathers
and great-grandfather's death
certificates and i tried to figure out
what my genetic envelope might look like
and then working backwards i tried to
ask the question do you want to give six
more years of service and I never could
get my family to state an opinion about
it in fact when in desperation I got
everybody on a conference call and say
look this is going to affect your lives
I want to know what you think so my baby
son said look pop do whatever makes you
happy but you need to know what the
first possible moment will don't throw
your ass and nursing home and take your
money and
my mother with always the appropriate
question said you rang when you an
intensive care and you dine you're going
to be glad you spent six more years in
the Senate and come to think of it that
was the relevant question so I decided
to quit while I was ahead I gave 24
years the service of the greatest state
the greatest country in the history of
the world and I loved every minute of it
for the last nine years I've been in
investment banking i worked for UBS I
was there for the 55 years I've been
there for the for skinny years the 55
years were better I I have been to
Hillsdale before I came sometime around
nineteen eighty I'm sorry 1970 I was a
young college professor and I came here
and gave a talk on energy and then I
came back with David Stockman in 1979 or
1980 I've known Larry for a very long
time I think very highly of him and I
think very highly of everything that
Hillsdale stands for
you
I always urge my friends that have money
to put your money where your principles
are don't give money to a school simply
because you went there my wife went to
Wellesley she's proud of it but we would
never give the money I want to talk
about Ronald Reagan and about
reaganomics and I want to try not to do
what so many people like me do it when
they're asked to speak on subjects like
this and that is I don't want to get off
from one Ronald Reagan story after
another I I had had an opportunity to
get to know President Reagan before he
was elected and I can remember vividly
when he took the oath and gave his
speech thinking that all my life my
views what I stood for what I believed
in had been hopelessly out of fashion
and that I really never expected to live
to have a president who felt exactly
like I did and I determined that day on
the western side of the Capitol that I
wasn't gonna waste this opportunity and
I'm proud to say that I did not let me
talk a little bit about the world into
which reaganomics was born the 1970s for
a myriad of reasons were not a happy
period we had a combination of
stagnation and inflation the inflation
rate peaked at 13 and a half percent
prime interest rates for a very short
period of time
were 21 and a half percent and we
awakened to the fact that we had shared
our secret economic freedom with the
world they were beginning to practice it
it wasn't that we were so much worse
than we'd ever been but all of our
competitors were better and i had to
quote jimmy carter a malaise had set
into America and there were real
questions real honest-to-god questions
about whether or not time had passed
america by was in the headline of Time
magazine the joy ride over did we really
need as jimmy carter said to learn to
live on less was less more and this
debate in the 1970s is what drew me into
public office neither of my parents
graduated from high school I was sort of
a product of American opportunity and
the idea that the age of America was
over was unthinkable to me the problem
was I didn't know many people the people
I knew didn't like me and so I set out
on a political quest driven by values to
run for public office and so I arrived
in Washington two years before Ronald
Reagan did I was from the south my
grandmother thought all Republicans were
those guys in blue shirts who had burned
down her grandmother's house I've never
met a Republican until I was grown now I
knew by the time i was elected to
Congress that it was a difference
between how most republicans thought
most democrats thought but those
differences didn't make any difference
to be I found when I got to Washington I
was the only
first they didn't make any difference
too well when ronald reagan came two
years later i wasn't gonna let parties
stand between me and what i had come to
washington to do and i had the great
privilege of helping to put together and
helping to pass the reagan program now
ray Reaganomics was as old as economics
and it was brand new the old part was
that water wet sand fire burns and
basically you have to make decisions
about how you're going to allocate
resources that you can have unlimited
freedom and unlimited government that
government in the 1970s was too big too
powerful too expensive and we didn't
want it even if it was free and these
were all ideas which Reagan explained
well and very credibly in terms people
could understand but there was a new
element to Reagan reaganomics and I
think looking back it was a very
powerful element now it was not new to
economist but it was new to the
political debate and the idea sounds
trivial when you talk about it but it
was a very powerful idea and the idea
was that tax rates affect people's
incentives to work save and invest and
if you have lower rates you create more
economic energy and that economic energy
generates economic activity and that
produces a flow of revenues to the
government and this was a theory that
was honed by art laffer and the press
is that presented it as the new part of
his program and it was new politically
and at first the public the media was
totally skeptical the public was
skeptical but in the end the program
worked and I want to talk about the
program tonight because the program was
not about personality it wasn't about
political parties it was about policy
and the test was does the policy work
and it did now there were some
inconvenient constraints that Reagan had
when he took office that could have
easily made it impossible for his
program to succeed we were in the
process with the support of the
president of breaking the back of
inflation and America and the Federal
Reserve Bank had tightened down on the
money supply in 1981 in 1982 and the
economy had slipped into the steepest
recession in the post-war period
secondly we were faced with a challenge
of the Soviet Union that was on the
march all over the world we were in
retreat in virtually every area of the
world and present reagan was determined
to rebuild national defense as part of a
program of peace through strength
neither of these constraints work to our
advantage in the battle of reviving the
american economy they both work strongly
against us so at the end of the speech
i'm going to compare the reagan recovery
to the current recovery and the point
that i want you to keep in mind is we
have had the most accommodating monetary
policy in the history
America in this current recovery in the
Reagan recovery we had a very
restrictive monetary policy and very
much to his credit Reagan understood
that inflation had to be broken and he
never complained about what the Fed was
doing and he was always supportive now
it took a special political coalition to
pass the Reagan program because when the
president was elected Republicans won
the senate but they did not win the
house in fact the democrats at their
lowest point had a 26th vote margin in
the House of Representatives fortunately
two years before a group of conservative
Democrats all of them from the south and
the border states had put together a
group trying to begin to get a debate
going about deficits and about the
explosion of government and the
Democrats were so confident in their
control of government that it didn't
matter to them what we were doing it
seemed irrelevant to the debate and then
all of a sudden when the votes were
counted in November of 1980 this group
of roughly 30 Democrat congressman that
I was actively involved in became part
of the governing majority in the House
of Representatives now Reagan was able
to take the case for his program above
Congress's head to the American people
and there's no doubt about the fact that
Reagan was a great communicator and that
that was a critical ingredient but i
guess i would say having been there
every day during this
battle that while Reagan was a great
communicator the key was not his ability
to communicate it was the ideas he was
communicating Reagan always claimed even
to the day left office that he was not a
great communicator he was a communicator
of great ideas and I agree with that and
what we had to do was to convince every
Republican we could lose to Republicans
if we could hold the 26 Democrats we had
and the 26 Democrats never wavered but
right at the end about 40 Republicans
started to waver now you don't remember
this but the Reagan program was a tough
program it eliminated three social
security benefits in one day kill them
cold turkey boom it killed the adults
student benefit the minimum benefit and
the death benefit in one day in windowed
and it was a dramatic change in public
policy and what happened i want to share
one reagan story with you because i
think it tell you something about the
man and how he worked and how he led the
president called me and said you know we
got about 40 Republicans that are
threatening to revolt do you think we
ought to try to begin to make some
orjinal changes in the program and i
said well i would be willing to make
changes but here's the problem if we
start making changes we sort of lose the
moral high ground that this is a
coherent program and i'm afraid for
everybody that we put something back
that they want there will be three more
members who will want something else and
the
old thing could unravel so anyway the
president never told me what he had
concluded but the next day 40
Republicans along with myself were
invited down to the White House and
everybody said around the extended
cabinet table and so reagan came into
the meeting and he said well I didn't
come to to give you a pep talk you all
know what the program is about I came to
listen to you and so he put his hand on
the shoulder of the guys that makes the
president I wish I remembered who it was
but anyway this guy said well mr.
president I'm with you I'm for this
program my problem is my constituency
and it must have sounded great because
by the time we got all the way around
that table about 75% of the members of
Congress that were this meeting had said
almost identically the same thing it
wasn't them it was their constituency
and so anyway I have not the Fed the
time not the foggiest idea what the
president was going to say and so he set
there and it felt like five minutes of
just silence and of course everybody's
eyes just glued on the president I mean
these were heady times and then he said
well I must have been confused I thought
this was about country I didn't know
this was about constituency
and he got up and left and let me tell
you the miracle not one person in that
room voted against the Reagan program it
passed by one vote if one person had
voted the other way the Berlin Wall
might still be standing fall under now
what did the Reagan program do and what
was born in America all about and I
don't want to bore you with statistics
but I want to just talk about what a
difference government makes what a
difference good policies make to real
honest-to-god people and so let me start
by talking about morning in America by
saying that I believe and I think the
evidence is overwhelming that the Reagan
program when fully implemented in 1983
brought in a 25-year golden age in
America it was 25 years where we had
very rapid economic growth we had only
two recessions in 25 years whereas we
had had four recessions in the previous
12 years and two of those were big
recessions the two recessions we had in
25 years with very very minor recessions
now what was this morning in America
about well Reagan as everybody knows
through his program cut the top tax rate
from seventy percent fifty percent
twenty-eight percent now it's tempting
to say well that's the top tax rate and
that was helping rich people and of
course it was as I used to try to
explain in Congress no person poor than
me ever hired me in my life if America
is going to be saved I used to say it's
going to be
at a profit and when there was a profit
it was saved I'm happy to say but just
listen to these numbers in 1979 the top
one percent of income earners in america
paid 18.6 percent of the total tax bill
by the year 2006 they were paying 39.1
percent of the total tax bill the top
ten percent of americans in 1979 were
paying 48.1 percent of all taxes by 2006
the last date we have good numbers they
were paying 72.8 percent the top forty
percent of all taxpayers in 79 were
paying 85.1 percent and by 2006 they
were paying 98.7 percent for all
practical purposes all the taxes the
bottom forty percent in 1979 paid four
point six percent and by 2006 they were
getting three-point-three percent in
direct payments of the Treasury in fact
the Treasury has become the largest
welfare institution in American society
more money is paid out through the
Treasury than all the welfare programs
the country combined economic growth
which in the 12 years prior to the
Reagan program had averaged 2.5% for the
following 25 years average
three-point-three percent now when you
drop that down to per capita income here
are the numbers in the 12 years prior to
the Reagan program going into effect per
capita GDP in real terms grew by one
point five percent for the 25 years
after the Reagan program real per capita
income grew by two-point-two percent now
to put that into
all our figures for the average American
because the Reagan program the average
American by 2006 was making seven
thousand four hundred dollars more than
they would have made under the growth
rates of the previous 12 years for the
Reagan program and a family of four was
making 29,000 602 dollars more as a
result of the expansion and growth that
I believe came directly from the Reagan
program in the 12 years prior to the
Reagan program America created 1.3
million jobs a year we would kill for
that number today but in the Reagan
years job growth was two million a year
and that means that as of 2006 there
were seven ten there was 17.5 million
more Americans at work that would have
been working under the growth rates of
the pre Reagan era inflation which had
been seven point six percent for the
previous 12 years felled a three point
one percent interest rates plummeted the
average house in America had a monthly
payment of one thousand dollars a month
less as a result of the success of the
Reagan program poverty which had grown
in the 1970s despite massive increases
in anti-poverty programs plummeted
despite cuts in poverty programs under
the Reagan program the poverty level
fell from fifteen percent to 11.3
percent those results or tangible
evidence that government matters that
policy matters now I'm not saying we
didn't make mistakes we in essence
took fifty percent of Americans off the
tax rolls in order to get the lower
rates we decided that it would be good
politics to simply raise the deductions
and take people completely off the tax
rolls in my opinion that was a mistake
and I think we are suffering from it
today I believe everybody ought to pay
income taxes no matter how low
but given the net result you still got
to give that work even in Hillsdale
College that would be an a now let me
conclude by comparing the Reagan
recovery to the recovery that we are in
today we are in the most disappointing
recovery of the post-war period by a big
margin even though we read about how
disappointing it is in the paper every
day I don't think people understand what
an outlier this recovery period is if
the economy had recovered from this
recession at the rate it recovered from
the 1982 recession which was roughly the
same size in terms of unemployment we
would have 16 point three million more
Americans at work today that would
employ everybody who says are unemployed
plus almost sixty percent of the
discouraged workers who have dropped out
of the labor force both the Reagan
program and the Obama program instituted
dramatic changes one program worked and
the other program failed if per capita
income had grown in this recovery at the
same rate it grew in the Reagan recovery
per capita income would be five thousand
one hundred thirty nine dollars higher
now those are not abstract numbers those
are real numbers that affect real people
in the end policy makes a difference
when you have good policy you have good
result Americans are not the most
brilliant talented people in the world
the plain truth is is that what we all
love our ancestors Americans are pretty
ordinary people what is unique about
America is that we have had a system
that's let ordinary people like us
achieve extraordinary things and if we
bring that system back and improve it
and I'm always amazed that looking at
how bad government is even in the best
of times if we really had good
government what we would be capable of
doing and if we have good policies we
will have good results and a final point
it's not just about money it's not just
about GDP it's about the kind of people
we are if you have Frances government
your people are going to become
Frenchman
if you watch television and you watch
these greek civil servants you would
think they were victimized instead of
victimizers their policies have made
them what they are what made you who you
are is the freedom and responsibility
you've had and if we lose it it's not
just about prosperity it's not just
about prices it's about who we are it's
about our character I have a guy who
does bulldozer work on my ranch and he
doesn't know a lot about foreign policy
knows a lot about the economics of the
bulldozing business but he's the equal
of any man he's the stuff empires are
made out of he's proud he's independent
he knows what he does as well as anybody
in America knows what they do that's
what America's about and so for me this
battle as it was in nineteen eighty as
it is today is not just about prosperity
it's not just about goods and services
it's about freedom and it's about the
kind of character that only freedom
creates so with that let me stop and
throw it open for questions
thank you very much let
let me say before we start the questions
when I went to Washington I could hear
perfectly well but people yelled at me
all those years and so I don't hear too
good so please talk right into the
microphone and then if I still don't
understand our last Paul what you said
his leaders look good so I'd be very
happy to try to answer any questions dr.
Graham can you hear me as as you know
better than I our country has suffered
as has must much of the world from the
financial crises that have occurred in
the last few years some of the people
analyzing the causes of that with the
idea of avoiding it from happening again
in the same way have suggested that some
of the glass-steagall changes perhaps
are appropriate anymore in view of the
factors that caused the problems and I
wondered what your view was on that well
let me first say that everything I did
when I was public life I did because I
believed in but that's not who I am it's
not you know it's not part of my
personality if I thought my banking
reforms were wrong I would say so I
don't see any evidence that they had
anything to do with the financial crisis
and I would also say that while
President Obama campaigned against
gramm-leach-bliley when he had total
control over both houses of Congress and
could have rewritten the law anyway he
wanted to write it he not only didn't
repeal it but he strengthened it by
bringing systemically significant
financial institutions that weren't
banks
under the law and making them financial
services holding companies the financial
crisis in my opinion is very simple to
explain in fact I was asked by the
governor of the People's Bank of China
in 2009 to in one sentence explained to
him what caused it and it was a pretty
tall order but I thought of it and I
said we loaned a whole bunch of money to
a whole bunch of people who either
couldn't have wouldn't pay it back and
the government had a policy to force
banks to make subprime loans under sea
already to force freddie and fannie to
buy them under the quota system where at
the end 59.7 percent of all the paper
they held had to be subprime and what
happened is the quality of mortgages
started to decline and these mortgages
were bundled into securities and then
injected into the arteries of the
financial system of the world and so
when mortgages started to default it
created a situation where nobody knew
which banks were affected and by how
much and we lost the indispensable
ingredient in modern finance and that
was trust interestingly enough the one
area totally unchanged by the so-called
dodd-frank bill is anything having to do
with the problem itself the bill and I
won't go on about it but the bill
basically has an agenda of expanding
government control over the banking
system and politicizing banking
decisions it is so burdensome in terms
of red tape and regulation that I would
be willing to predict here that if it is
not repealed or substantially changed
that within ten years one
urn of all the banks the America will be
out of business because the small banks
can't compete the regulatory costs are
just so great they can't compete senator
senator Graham you and Rick Perry are
from the same caste equally tough I
think he is the strongest and best
candidate on the other hand he's being
excoriated for his position on
immigration do you think this will sink
his candidacy the answer is no I don't
think that issue will sink his Candice
the in-state tuition is for residents
not citizens if the federal government
won't enforce the immigration laws and
people are here is suicidal not to
educate them so I agree with the
Governor on this issue I think his
challenge is that he had never planned
to run and pressure build up and he
decided to run and so he hadn't done it
before he hadn't spent four years
preparing to do it and it's a tough task
if he can learn enough fast enough he'll
win the nomination but you know it's
like the old cliche is trying to drink
my fire hose
senator Graham first of all I'd like to
thank you for coming to speak to us and
I'd like to thank you for your service
to America but my question is could you
outline a specific public policy plan
economically that we could use today to
get America back on track yeah I haven't
I mean I've I guess I always am
outlining plans but i think a logical
thing to do is basically pick a period
say 2006 where and then ask ourselves a
question did we have two little
government 2006 were we suffering from a
lack of government 2007
and I think the answer's no and so why
don't we take spending back to where it
was in 2006 and look everybody knows
what's got to be done in entitlements
it's not rocket science the problem is
created by the fact that people having
fewer babies and people are living
longer and our entitlement programs were
based on the Bismarck model bismarck
when a unified germany started the
modern entitlement and it was a
brilliant idea of in a country with a
lot of young people in very few old
people with a high birth rate and a high
death rate to guarantee benefits and
skip a generation by simply taking the
money from young people and giving it to
old people and the old people would get
a benefit they never paid for the only
problem with that program and we have it
is it creates no wealth and it doesn't
benefit from what Einstein called the
most powerful force in the universe
compound interest so now we're closing
in on two workers for every retiree and
it can't work and there's no tax rate at
which it will work that society won't
collapse under its weight and so what
we've got to do the following things in
my opinion number one we've got to
continue phasing up the retirement age
at its current rate not to 67 but 270
number two we've got to index Social
Security in the future not by the wage
rate but by prices private pensions
r-nev indexed by prices those are
changes that are no-brainers in my
and you're not cutting social security
you're just not increasing it as much in
Medicare you've got to have a system
where you got co-payments and
deductibles based on income so for
example I would be covered by Medicare
but I'd have to spend fifty thousand
dollars in one year before the
government started paying and it would
then pay 25 cents on the dollar and the
poorest person in the country might have
a hundred-dollar deductible and a two
dollar co-payment but everybody would
have a deductible and a co-payment and
you would adjust the deductible the
co-payment based on the cost of the
program and if people want to stay in
the old program under that system they
could if they wanted to go into Paul
Ryan's program and have insurance like
Congress they could I don't think
raising the retirement age on the
Medicare is a good idea it's one thing
for me to keep working when I'm old I
don't know anything but work but I find
when I get up on a ladder cutting
branches out of trees or trying to paint
under a porch I have a hard time doing
it now whereas I used to do it and never
think about it so there's some lines of
work where you can't keep working when
you're 70 years old and I'm afraid that
if we if we've been in and Obama's
proposed this I'm afraid if we do that
we're inviting socialized medicine to
come in and take its place so I wouldn't
do that I think in terms of all of these
things we pay people to do if the
markets not demanding it if people don't
want it we shouldn't do it I there not
many deductibles in the tax code that I
get terribly excited about I would much
rather have lower rates and I do think
we could create more growth
with lower tax rates those are the basic
programs i think we need to get we need
to repeal Obamacare we need to shut down
his regulatory machine we need to get
back to competing I spend a lot of time
in China and there are many things about
the Chinese system that I admire hard
work unleashed energy from a new freedom
people have never had and as kind of
unseemly that the greatest country in
the history of the world goes around
complaining about other people not
solving our problems I don't know what
it's like in your family but people
don't come solve my problems I wish they
would my mother used to when I was a
child but my mother's dead and now I
have to do it America has to do it we
don't need any help we have had the
highest wage rates in the world since
the colonial period never has an English
settler or anybody who came since work
today in America we had and I had the
highest wage rates on earth and yet
we've competed because we've done it
better and if you're going to try to
produce the same old thing the same old
way you're not going to do it not in the
world we live in so you can wish it away
but look here's what happened people
looked at Americans said I want what
they have and so they're copying our
system and the world's better off
because of it the changes in China
irreversible and China's not going away
Korea's not going away Turkey's not
going away we're going to have to learn
to compete again and we can that's the
good news i don't have any doubt about
it
but we're going to have to do new things
we've got to do them better people are
going to have to change nobody is
guaranteed that they can do the same job
forever and we change better than
everybody else and we've got to learn to
change even better than we have that's
my program
thanks again senator Graham you were a
very eloquent especially in your defense
of freedom and you're connecting with
character and generally I agree with you
but there are a few points where I think
a free market may become detrimental to
character as we see in the Internet has
become in some ways a cesspool of
unrighteousness and economic freedom is
very important but I'm not sure that
it's enough I mean would you speak to
that enough to guarantee character okay
well there are markets for good things
and there are markets for bad things
there are markets for things like
abortion and pornography and I don't
think those are good things now i'm not
sure that the government should
legislate against them but if we're
talking about increasing freedom and
increasing character those don't seem to
be as simply connected as you made them
and I'd like to hear more on that okay
let me let me make it clear that what
I'm talking about economic freedom i'm
talking about economic freedom within
the rule of law criminal activities do
not represent economic freedom they
violate economic freedom but with
economic freedom i'm talking about the
ability to p of people to use their
god-given talent to produce and sell
things that don't harm other people and
a chance of people to get on the playing
field and a reduction in the ability of
people who are already on the playing
field to keep them off those are the
things that I'm talking about
we got to roll
thank you I'm wondering from your
perspective why poverty has just been so
stubborn and as our approach just
totally inadequate well I don't think
our programs have been inadequate I
think they've been wrong I wonder what I
would be like if we had had welfare
programs when I was a child my mama
worked in a cotton mill for eight
dollars a week she would never she would
went to her grave saying she would never
have taken welfare but if she lived
today everybody she would know would be
taking it people with mocker for not
taking it she would probably take it I
don't know what my world would be like
much of what we see as poverty today is
a monument to the failure of our program
and I hope I don't offend anybody but
look at Detroit Michigan a great city
that at one time was the model of what
American productivity was about and look
at it and today what produced that bad
government I wonder sometimes what the
world would be like we'd never had a
welfare program now I know it would have
been hard on individuals but I wonder
how many more happy productive people we
would have and I don't know about you
but when I Drive past these blighted
areas and I see people just wandering
around to me just the wasted lives is
heartbreaking and government produce
that and if we change the policies will
change the people yeah there was a guy
in the bayou looks like it's subversive
yeah
who's young favor you gotta watch you
never know what god thank you for being
here dr. Graham my question is as we've
seen presidential candidate Herman Cain
gained a lot of momentum in the last few
weeks in part because of his economic
and economic growth plan the 999 plan
that we've heard a lot about I would
like to hear your opinion of that plan
and whether or not you think it would
work well I I don't know Herman Cain I
have been impressed by him I think he is
a great image for the Republican Party
and
maybe I'm just old and jaded but I think
at this point that either Perry or
Romney is going to be the nominee let me
tell you my problem with the 999 thing
in the 1970s Europe brought in the
value-added tax under the pledge that it
was ultimately going to replace the
income tax and it didn't and if you look
at the size of American governments
compared to European government it was
in that period where between five and
ten percentage points of GDP distance
was created and I would never support a
value-added tax unless we repeal the
16th amendment and eliminated the income
tax what I don't want is a new form of
taxes now I never got very excited about
tax reform I'm very much in favor of it
it's so obvious that we ought to have a
simpler system with fewer deduction than
lower rates but anything you do can be
gained gained even with a value-added
tax you can have premiums for higher
price commodities and so in the end the
debate is more about how much government
is going to spend than it is about how
you collect it now you can collect it
more or less efficiently I certainly
agree with that but in the end I have
always cared most about keeping
government small I believe there is a
limit beyond which you can't let
government grow without endangering
freedom even the best government in
history of the world government is
inherently inefficient will always be
inefficient no matter who is president
it's inefficient when you are spending
somebody else's money you do not spend
it as a
efficiently as you do your own and
therefore government should be kept as
small as we can keep it consistent with
the clear needs of the public like
public health national defense and I
would apply a ella pages test if it's in
the yellow pages you can buy it in the
private sector government all not to be
doing it
now that probably dates me there's
probably not a student at this College
you've ever looked in the elevator they
somehow turn on this machine and it just
pops things just just come forward it's
some miracle yeah I've got one more
question hello thank you for speaking
tonight you've talked a lot about
incentives from the federal government
on a personal level and I was just
wondering if you could talk about maybe
some business incentives from the
federal government how they're
structured and maybe how we could
improve on them just I was wondering if
you could talk about the federal like
business incentives from a federal level
and how maybe we could improve on them
business incentives sorry well one of
the first things I'd get rid of his
business incentives if you need
if you need incentives to do something
you probably ought not to do it and look
solar energy is a perfect example I use
solar energy on my ranch and I use wind
energy why because it's cheaper than
either using a diesel-powered generator
or running a line three miles so I'm
using it because it's efficient but it
is not efficient where you got access to
conventional electricity solar power has
been around a long time and it is going
to come into general use if and when it
becomes competitive I know this is a
shocking revelation to government but
new technologies are adopted if and only
if they are cheaper when you count all
costs they are never you never adopt
quote more expensive technologies is not
the way the world works and we're going
to end up squandering vast amounts of
money in electric cars that nobody is
going to buy except people who want to
to make a statement which is great I
just want them to make it with their
money
and if you want to cover your roof up
with solar panels great but don't make
me pay for it and we're not going to
make it efficient any faster these
projects that were funding are not new
technology you know with pure research
there's a case that can be made for
government funding but once you get into
commercialization there is no case that
can be made engineering physics maybe
something government can fund but
engineering is not and I think that's a
very bright line and I I would always
recognize it i would never step over it
well let me conclude by saying thank you
so much for having me and let me say to
the students who are here you're a very
blessed to be in a place where people
still believe in and advocate freedom it
is the only real revolutionary idea in
history the old idea that somewhere
somebody knows better than you or that
government can solve problems but those
are old tried tested and failed ideas
the revolutionary idea of our time is
the idea that free men and women given
the ability to use that freedom within
the rule of law can become the richest
freest and happiest people in the world
and a beacon to the world that the whole
world aspires to amen
you
I